[Música]
el día mundial del agua se celebra el 22
de marzo de cada año y su principal
objetivo es crear conciencia de la
importancia de cuidar el líquido vital
para los seres humanos y las especies en
nuestra tierra asimismo se busca
concientizar sobre la problemática de
los millones de personas que no tienen
acceso al suministro de agua potable y
las medidas urgentes que se deben tomar
al respecto para hacer frente a este
gran problema esto 2022 el tema se
centra en importancia de las aguas
subterráneas un recurso que no se ve
pero que influye en el equilibrio del
agua también del planeta y el que
dependen los ecosistemas las aguas
subterráneas se encuentran en los
acuíferos que alimentan los ríos lagos
humedales y los manantiales las aguas
subterráneas también se alimentan de la
lluvia y la nieve y se filtra en los
océanos sin ellas la vida sería casi
imposible incluso en las regiones más
áridas de nuestro planeta podemos
encontrar agua subterránea y para ello
entonces le doy la bienvenida a nuestro
segundo invitado del día el es carlos
ocurre a artista medioambiental además
creadora del famoso frailejón ernesto
pérez en colombia pero antes de hablar
de eso a hablar de las políticas
responsables para cuidar el agua carlos
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 cuáles son
esas políticas que debería a lo mejor
implementar un gobierno para cuidar
nuestro recurso vital
principalmente debes tener muy en cuenta
que el agua es un elemento que nos
estamos acabando lentamente por medio de
las empresas por medio del consumo
masivo entonces pues que pueden
implementar pues tomar conciencia
siempre tomar conciencia y tenerla como
prioridad sobre todo en cuanto al
consumo masivo y en cuanto a las
consumos las empresas siempre tenerlo
como presente hacia ellos cuidar también
los ecosistemas carlos la importancia de
los páramos sobre todo en nuestra región
andina latinoamericana hablamos de los
páramos colombianos los páramos de
venezuela porque la importancia de los
páramos y también estábamos conversando
de nuestra huella hídrica la que usamos
nosotros para sobre todo
el cultivar nuestros alimentos
bueno los paramos principalmente pues
por eso estamos llamando el frailejón no
que son los que absorben la tienen una
posibilidad muy grande de absorber los
deseos y purificar el agua para
llevarlos a nosotros hacia nosotros
nuestros nuestros consumos nuestro
consumo y la huella hídrica pues
principalmente pues nosotros ya estamos
en el cultivo de plantas y en el cultivo
de lo que consumimos
mucho mucha mucha mucha agua
y cómo podemos ayudar con eso pues
primero que todo pues alimentándonos
bien no si no vamos a consumir algo en
nuestra comida como observamos a todos
no comamos todo lo que consumimos y lo
que no pues guardemos lo sigamos no sea
un tomate un tomate gasta 240 litros de
arles de agua y si lo dejamos ahí porque
no estará un poco más bullado y no se
que entonces pues más bien cogemos de
ese tomate y lo guardamos y miramos a
ver cómo lo podemos reutilizar como
consumir y la comida que no podemos
comer lo que porque estamos llenos o
cualquier cosa entonces pues guardiola y
la usamos para más tarde o cualquier
cosa eso podemos hacer con el agua que
ya sea que se ha gastado no podemos
regresar al agua pero tampoco
desperdiciarla no vamos por el camino
correcto e incorrecto a su opinión en
nuestra región en américa latina y al
caribe con el cuidado del agua
somos muy desperdiciamos mucho el agua o
por el contrario si estamos tomando cada
día un poco más de conciencia sobre este
recurso pues yo espero que estemos
tomando conciencia con el agua porque si
hay muchas partes en donde
consumimos muchísimo osea yo veo en un
jardín o que lava en el suelo con agua
con una por agua presión inicial pero
pero de haber otras maneras de hacerlo
mucho más fácil y no malgastarlo no en
el turismo en el turismo la gente deja
cosas votadas y se les olvida que está
en un sitio que no es su hogar o cosas
así y esto es mejor como recogerlas y
llevárselas para su casa no con ellas
porque las cosas podemos ayudar el agua
muy muy muy muy fuerte nos podemos dar
un apoyo muy grande hacia el agua
haremos ahora los frailejones la
importancia de los frailejones en
nuestros páramos también para la
creación del agua porque son tan
importantes los frailejones bueno los
reuniones que hacen como ellos cogen y
todo el co2 que nosotros hemos hemos
mandado al aire y demás ellos lo cogen
lo absorben y purifican eso es agua por
medio de la nieve la lo absorben y lo
con flo purifican y eso lo transmiten
hacia los ríos ellos absorben ese agua
lo mantienen en su cuerpo
lo absorben y cuando hay épocas de
sequía y cosas así entonces lo vuelven y
lo regresan a su a su flujo natural no
entonces por eso ayudan mucho los los
fresones hacia hacia él hacia el agua no
por eso creo entonces usted el personaje
famoso sobre todo aquí en colombia el
frailejón ernesto pérez es un éxito cómo
nació esta idea y porque además estambre
porque ernesto pérez ernesto pérez el
resolver él le puso el papá entonces
esto pérez un chiquitín muy bonito que
le gusta leer le gusta cantar y el papá
le puso así y él quiere pues dar su
mensaje a la humanidad de que por favor
cuiden el agua por favor que en los
páramos y pues todo el ecosistema no
selvas bosques glaciares todo que tengan
mucha conciencia de dónde están parados
para poder que desnudos de un poco más
no hasta dónde quieren llegar a ustedes
con ernesto pérez cuál es la huella
principal digamos que usted que ustedes
le quieren dar a los niños en el cuidado
nuestro nuestro planeta nuestro medio
ambiente a los niños de los adultos
ahora porque ellos
está escuchando y es eso tomen
conciencia tomen conciencia del donde
estamos parados estamos en una tierra en
donde estamos nosotros como habitantes
pero también somos parte de esta de esta
amistad no de este flujo y de esta
relación que tenemos con la tierra
entonces tengan cuidado o sea lo que
dice la canción tengan cuidado con el
agua cuiden el agua con el agua como lo
hace frailejón ernesto pérez para que
esto nos dure muchísimo más y tengamos
mucho más
una relación más amistad más
más estrella de era más estrechas y con
la tierra ahora como carlos se han
aprovechado ustedes toda esta vitalidad
con el personaje de ernesto pérez para
seguir educando para seguir generando
conciencia me imagino también que muchos
medios de comunicación le han invitado a
sus distintos programas para seguir
generando conciencia como ha sido todo
esto ha sido muy hermoso la verdad hemos
podido llegar a llevar el mensaje mucho
más allá de lo que era pues con títulos
mágicos que es de donde viene frailejón
ernesto pérez y puede seguir mandando el
mensaje para todos queremos llegar este
orden y también con una idea de que el
frailejón pues les enseña a todos cómo
que bueno estamos acá y estamos en un
sitio donde no nos conocemos y en donde
no conocemos el espacio cuidémoslo ahora
hacemos todas las cositas que tengamos
para ir nuevo tenemos nos regimos y
reciclamos reciclamos lo que más podamos
no consumamos tanto sino lo que
necesitamos no utilizar el agua para lo
que necesitamos este tipo de material
para la educación de los niños y también
de los adultos digamos está este
material animado piensan distribuirlo a
lo mejor en en américa latina que tenga
expansión más allá de las fronteras
colombianas claro que sí
vemos que con tintes mágicos llegue a
todos los niños del mundo porque porque
nos estamos dando un mensaje más allá
del ecosistema darle valores a los niños
ya los alumnos pequeños pues que pueden
aprender muchas cosas aprendiendo con
canciones pero cosas que yo que quieren
ustedes entonces
hacer como digamos al corto plazo con
esto de cuentitos más cosa además
contextualizamos un poco de nuestra
audiencia de que son nuestros cuentos
mágicos encuentros mágicos es una serie
animada que está hecho para niños de
ignacio escuín frailejones no esto pérez
pero hay muchos personajes está el coco
está la zanahoria que enseña hacer
ejercicio están los cocos que enseñan a
ir a la playa y broncearse y bañarse
están mitocondria que es una chica en
por empoderada y que le enseña a las
chicas pues que no tiene que estar dando
pues si quiere jugar con muñecas está
bien pero también se hay que construir
también está perfectamente bien
está bueno hay muchísimos personajes
enseñando a estar bien con familia a
compartir como la familia a quererse con
los hermanos a compartir
bueno cuidar el ecosistema claro está
bueno infinidades entonces pues queremos
que cuentito médicos llegue para todos
para enseñarles a ellos a todo el mundo
ya los niños que hay unas formas y
valores que tenemos que tener en cuenta
y que nos pueden ayudar a estar en
empatía con todos no a tener una
relación de estrecha con toda la tierra
carlos y por supuesto no lo voy a dejar
ir del estudio de france 24 en español
sin cantar la famosa canción del fraile
con
no
no no mi nombre es claro y le funcionó
esto pérez que te quiero saludar tú me
conoces dir pero yo a ti sí sí yo soy tu
amigo tu amigo fraile fundió el mismo
mes te vengo a saludar soy una planta
sin mucho con lo cuida del agua es mi
profesión yo soy tu hijo tu amigo fraile
junio nuestro merece y te vengo a
enseñar camarín dulces antes de dormir
notas de samba si no es digno si me
quisiera saber si te hace cepillar y la
basura es aprendas a reciclar
nada nada lalalala yo soy tu amigo todo
me compra y me jode una experiencia pero
con mi papá que diga de un afán que
contribuirá al agua como lo cuido yo te
digo niño te digo no a ti que seas
guerra mundo de profesión y apaguen
luces antes de dormir no gastes agua si
no es conseguir que el cierre llave si
te hace ser billar y las basuras
aprendas a reciclar que cuides plantas
para jugar
no olvides nunca que yo te cuidaré yo
soy tu amigo tu amigo frailejón ernesto
pérez y te enseñó una lección cuidado
del agua como un lago no
tu enojar muchísimas gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 hablando los del personaje el
frailejón ernesto pérez hoy 22 de marzo
el día internacional del agua para
concientizar para cuidar nuestros
recursos naturales carlos gracias por
estar con nosotros una hora de terrell
está de esta manera